I'd say if I think of people who my
found in other fields philosophy or even
law or elsewhere things i put together
that I remember I mean homes of course
was a very great judge and what of it he
because he saw what I admired in him and
my people do admire in him is he said
look it's it's not a question of a few
people dictating to others it is a
question of inspiring or leading or
getting others themselves to resolve
their problems sometimes when they
resolve their problems they run up
against what he called a can't help he
said it can't help I have a can't help
when I just have to say my god this is
wrong and we've seen a few of those so
it's like being under pressure it's like
you want these it's not my decision it's
not my decision it's their decision
they've got to do it they've got to work
this out I can give advice but I can't
tell anybody what to do and then you run
up against a can't help you can't do
that you can't do that you can't put
those people in prison without any cause
you can't do this kind of thing it's
just too much you say speech religion
whatever that's those I see those things
in the Constitution so i think it's a
it's an end homes was influenced by by
what i think of as the late 19th century
early 20th century American pragmatists
the pragmatists or henry james perse and
there's a pretty good book called the
metaphysical club I don't know if you've
seen it very good and he they described
he describes those of people at that
time and then I think of San Francisco
which was a cooperative western its
western it's open its cooperative its
people of all walks of life getting
together and trying to figure out how to
solve their problems and I think of when
I was going back growing up back in San
Francisco you said what was the world
supposed to be like well the world in a
way the Dean Acheson created or helped
create that was a world which was going
to be a world where democracy would
spread where people's basic rights
would be guaranteed where there would be
free trade not totally free the mixed
economy you see regulated but
competitive not communism not laisser
faire capitalism but there'd be
something in between there where you
take the advantages of free markets but
regulate them so they don't get out of
control and and there would be
international organizations whereby
people could resolve their international
disputes so you say put thats a
pragmatic but pragmatic pragmatic is is
is a pragmatism American pragmatism
Henry James and and purse and those
people it will and quine later on the
Philosopher's it's not just do whatever
is good it's not just look out and each
decision you try to maximize whatever is
good it is to try to create systems
rules organizations methods of
cooperation that you see over time will
tend to push society's towards what is
better I mean when he talked about truth
this is maybe more do you want to know
better but but when he talked about
truth James and purse were not saying
that something is true because it works
what they were saying is that something
is true because it's part of a total
system and that total system works
better for people than some alternative
systems